hello everyone yesterday was the end of
the round six of the Norway championship
11 our enemies tied for the first place
with Hikaru Nakamura and the next
caution is still without wind tied for
the last place Levin Arjan achieved
wonderful victories in Rome for in round
six and we shun and wasn't doing very
well although he did achieve a victory
against Fabiana Corwin and round six
so today the players are having the rest
day so I thought I'd show you a game
where we shot played a fantastic game
against Levin Arnhem this game is also
called an immortal or a game for the
game for the ages as the negative skull
can want to describe it so here is the
game the first couple of moves I'm not
going to analyze the excel tender theory
d4 d5 c4 c6 Knight f3 Knight of 6 like
c3 e 6 e 3 9b d7 Bishop to d3
he takes c4 a tempo variation and black
is waiting for the white bishop to
develop on d3 and only then will he
recapture on c4 we should take C 4 V 5
black captures the temple Bishop goes
back to be 3 Bishop to d6 White Castle
black castles Queen to c2 this has to be
7k 3 and here is where a man's home
preparation comes in two games rook the
c8 here a normal move a normal a central
moon would be pawn to a6 but here are
not prepared route to c8 and in a lot of
games were a6 was played the standard
continuation was the Knight to g5
threatening the pond on h7 but here
after route c8 our own young also
continued with the Knight g5
and this is where things get interesting
I don't think replace c5 he totally
disregards the threat on the h74 and
develops his bishop on b7 with the
strong diagonal to do the G 2 and H 1
Arizona captures nice takes an 87
resonator broken f8 and here on goes
Knight to g4 and although black is on a
form and his rook is hanging it kind of
seems like black is now on the attack
but both of his bishops are eyeing on
this kingdom g1 they have this nice
diagonal and it's kind of tricky
what Y could play if white captures and
f8 the queen is coming to h4 and it's
pretty much over for white so here are
going gave it a good try with the move a
step for he blocked this diagonal of the
dark square bishop and well he still up
a bone and still threatened to take mfa
parents to concede for them to come
before and this is a a mover after which
they decided to call this Anand immortal
Bishop to c5 so arm is basically
attacking to be for porn although the
bishop can be taken but if he takes e5
simply nice takes e5 and black is
already threatening to capture the
bishop on d3 she's also threatening
Queen to deport check which this ugly
discoveries and double checks so Harlan
didn't go for this she got a try with
Bishop to e2 trying to kick the night
from the G Force where and here under
find another fancy move to continue his
his immortal game he plays Knight to d5
and now this is a this is really
complicated and disgusting position I'm
not going are not even going to analyze
it you can analyze it by ourselves if
you like to this is what happens next
Bishop take is G for a now final takes
on d4 we should take B for chips into h1
nicely captures on g4
and now RM takes the rock and f8 and
here you think that black might be
tempted to go Queen to h4 and it really
seems like this is over there's really
no defense against all these threats
the bishop is on gonji to this bishop is
holding g1 Queens threatening checkmate
on h2 but it would actually be a pretty
big blunder as Queen to f7 check of
courses the trade of Queens and what it
simply all broke up so black has a
cigarette have to go but how to deal
about this and I don't place the simple
point where file and this pretty much
resolves the entire game so nice to g6
trying to save the night Queen to f6
white stripes with h3 point X - 2 xx x
on g6 Queen to d2
although capturing the night on g4
wouldn't really accomplish anything
simply click to h6 is checkmate
so R&M try to hold with Queen to e2 on
place Queen to h5 threatening this Agra
checkmate Windex h3 the Queen cannot be
taken because the king is spin from the
bishop on b7 and one let's try from our
next Queen to b3 trying to defense dh3
pawn and now the simple Bishop e3
blocking the Queen's the sense of the h3
pawn so is the bishop takes simply Queen
takes h3 checkmate and it's Queen takes
them
simply the night will capture White
Queen and it's game over so there's the
game I hope you enjoyed it
we've seen in round four and Rancic's
how our own young tears in dispositions
and how he well he destroyed the world
number one by Magnus Carlton and the
world number two was Emir Kramnik so I
thought it'd be fun to see a game where
he's on the other side of the board
receiving it from another former world
champion with an anthem Anand so yeah
this game I hope you enjoyed it and see
you soon